Minecraft's do you ever heard of that
about the game now we're gonna have more
of that game smash like minecraft
subreddit I don't know why I never
thought of this this is like free
content it's so obvious why have I not
reviewed the Minecraft subreddit yet
instead of me playing Minecraft you can
watch me reacting to other people
playing Minecraft grab your favorite
pickaxe and let's just dig straight down
into it alright my heart stopped for the
entire time ah I like her blazing
torches ah you just locked yourself in
boy ah see this is why you need to do
wow he made it or she girls can play
minecraft - I've been told it's true if
I played I would have killed them all
noob clearly not minecraft veteran oh my
god here it is this is the photo they
never came back
no don't make me think about what
happens when I die what happens this is
like Toy Story the point someone needs
to make a movie about this what happens
to your minecraft dog after you die I
made a role generator that doesn't add
biomes but improves on the vanilla ones
that's pretty cool I especially like the
trees that are inside the ground I like
the mountains though that's pretty dope
like the curves gets not she doesn't
like curbs for some reason I thought my
walking house could use a friend oh this
is a Mac Mecca Stein he's the guy that
did my PewDiePie boss fight I think yes
there it is
oh my god it controls see a lot of
people I think you telling me I should
start using mods in Minecraft now that
is so dope like modded survival is a
thing to kind of keep it fresh for you
and you can do this kind of stuff hey I
can snipe if you want to do another one
please finally trying minecraft at blank
terraria but something isn't quite right
that's pretty cool yeah I never played
terraria I remember though when terraria
came out it was like a lot of
controversy and people saying it was
copying it's just 2d minecraft see I'm a
veteran so I remember the old Greaves of
the past blast resistant walls using
waterlogged chairs stairs okay so these
walls can't blow up won't because of the
water on the side oh okay that's pretty
cool actually see I figure that see I
figured it out guys it's because it's
water on the side yeah I think I saw
this you want it think I mean so many
things in Minecraft that just makes no
sense but there's nothing to see the air
these are totally normal doors
wha-ha-ha let's create it god no okay
let's go just open the door place that's
good
that's funny don't zoom just a casual
picture of Chicago whoa someone looked
at Chicago and was like I can build that
Wow
I mean that is cool that's a cool
wallpaper mixed up solar system come on
gamers let's make the universe in
Minecraft then we never have to leave
but there's bees in Minecraft look how
happy that he is about it I don't know
am I allowed to play the new one because
I don't think you can spawn them without
cheating or should I just wait for the
actual update I feel like I should just
wait for the update I made a bee source
pack of course of course how to bring
dolphins home
what no they can go on this is good for
me I'm learning stuff what
no they're gonna dry out what is
happening so you threw a potion on them
to make them fly is that what's
happening what is he doing okay here we
go oh my god is he fly oh that's great
bringing my boys back ego oh that's
adorable
I made a data pack that lets you put
saddles on - oh my god okay I'm getting
the Beast and I'm and you can control
him with a flower and a stick that's
great
next wither battle I found a completely
buried
NPC house and this poor farmer in it so
I decided to give him a cozy place what
oh yeah sometimes they spawn randomly
Oh
his house is underground but he's a
zombie
oh that's so nice
oh god it's all about the bees now I
made my my friend Maeby's hit the
pufferfish
now to make pufferfish into bees that's
great name a better couple
I dare you name a more iconic duo my
render distance is low and this happened
that's terrifying
okay that's epic my mom made a cool
minecraft cake for my little cousin
along with another cake that has a
creeper face on it with frosting okay
Oh your mom wins congratulations you're
not to show it off
so me and my wet mate went to kill the
Ender Dragon I got blasted off into
oblivion while he destroyed the orbs I
ended up taking a quarter of its health
hitting it with a stake and half with my
friends trusty shovel whilst he shot it
my weapons have since been immortalized
in our base lol it sounds like your
friend killed the dragon while you just
beat it with the stake for no reason
okay and how do you not know how to do a
screen shot Jesus Christ is 2019 I'm
sorry but
ha ha ha this says a lot about parenting
same thing happened with me oh okay that
actually looks really cool I like that
so yeah I haven't followed that
development on minecraft in so long but
do they take community feedback and
stuff like that cuz that's really cool
actually see I knew about this trick
it's not it's not even that useful I
mean I would never shoot in Minecraft
hello next one that's so cute
notch we need penguins in Minecraft now
didn't I say that already there should
be penguins come on they need to do more
with the snow step my friend asked me to
sleep but he seems suspicious I was
wondering if you could do bunk beds
that's awesome damn goddammit what does
everyone build such cool stuff meanwhile
I just build a meat pole so he put glass
on the exterior of it it's nobody did I
I'm confused
ok that's a fake now I feel so useless
all this Saturn oh ok
whoa damn bruh how brah
stop stop
what ah okay that's cool well played
I made Squidward's infinity room what be
swear he's versus the wither there it is
someone's unhurt he done it god damn it
come on bees please oh damn damn bees
bees okay
that was epic freak that my friends by
going afk while looking up skipping a
day how to get banned from a server in
27 seconds okay you play some snow yes
wait you can make snow carpet okay yes
what does that do oh that's another way
to do it
oh I am learning so much about Minecraft
not that I need it though you can trick
a loyal Trident how Oh
what no cheat sheet for Trident it's
trying to help you
the council will decide Council of water
sheep alternate-universe can you build
that see I want to build that it's
awesome say I'm getting so many great
ideas to steal ah damn is that just Maps
place down I never used maps well that's
actually pretty cool hey by the way I've
been wanting to do this for a long time
seed here's my seed tell me we're all
the epics toughest I think my chicken
farm got a little out of hand
those are eggs damn see I haven't done
that yeah I haven't even built a
cathedral yet in Minecraft come on be
boats HD we have to capture bees in boat
come on
we have so much stuff left to do in
Minecraft my friend had a near-death
experience yesterday whoa whoa that is
so unlucky lucky I'm gonna see that
again all right so that's why you don't
place torches on the floor in front of
you Dan this Enderman is disappointed at
me that's great I made a house but every
block is eight by eight what does that
mean oh my god okay that's kind of cool
I made a working TV using command blocks
what the how dead wow I love the channel
that's really good just fell in love it
our room golem doesn't do his job
properly built him a deserted floating
island where I hope he will rethink his
actions illustrate I need to also make I
need to make like a punishment place
like the ranch an actual physical ranch
my god is that slime or what is
happening cool an unfortunate series Oh
God creepers man oh man just like oh man
walking up every block in Minecraft okay
alright I think I get it okay alright
there's a lot of box in Minecraft with
this your favorite block in Minecraft
mine is your mom's but I found out how
to get under bedrock
well you could just take a piston and
push yourself down come on what a noob
whoa okay well you're dead now
congratulations with your Electra
building a witch farm what how does that
work that's really dope though where do
they spawn in swamp they spawn in swamp
or oh yeah this is fun does it need to
be as even as possible or and that's to
get all the water out too damn grass is
growing
look how satisfying that is oh man
that's so much work god
I mean I respect the hustle but bro
seriously bro I think he was having a
bit of a bad day oh my god what are they
I didn't know pandas could somersault
that's awesome I mean it's terrible but
awesome I realized that sand floats on
public owns what that's so cool
what is this oh my god what bro what am
I looking so okay you're flipped alone
is cool and all but what about playing
Minecraft on a ti-84 plus C e damn
that's some nice framerate Chicago in
there buddy damn looks like you died
there buddy that sucks
oh man oh I wish I saw this that's so
much better
damn it you found a spawner next to your
base oh my god
no is that possible
isn't there a limit Jesus Christ oh my
god
just let them fight it out boys will be
boys you just gotta let them fight it
out
the Town Hall of Hamburg in Minecraft
good job excuse me what what
Oh minecraft the most realistic game I
just witnessed a murder no okay
I thought it would push it now okay ah
see now I don't feel as bad for doing
that the Council of dogs there's a lot
of councils I thought there was only one
council - thank you very much oh my god
they have a secret entrance I have a
secret engine interest in my council as
well thank you very much
[Laughter]
all right gamers that's it for this week
I almost said yet this is not a weekly
thing but it's a Minecraft thing so much
like if you enjoyed designed by me and
Marcia very epic check it out Sookie dot
market thank you very much and I'll see
you guys next time bye bye well you
haven't tried to pursue Malay turd city
after 50 million outros much now just
now it's still relevant just down a bit